[Musique]
Hélène buzetti Michel Coget à la
castongué bonsoir bonsoir
Amira be a fait beaucoup parler d'elle
aujourd'hui vendredi
nomination elle a été nommée un poste de
conseillère pour établir des ponts entre
la lutter contre l'islamophobie lutter
contre le racisme établir des pentes les
communautés bon bref ça c'est son poste
le problème dise plusieurs c'est je vous
montre en 2019 dans une entrevue
Ottawa c'était zen et dit
malheureusement dit-elle c'est dans la
foulée du débat sur la loi 21 sur le
voile la majorité des Québécois semble
être influencée non pas par l'État de
droit mais par un sentiment
anti-musulman
écrit-elle ce qui a fait dire un
ministre du gouvernement ministre
responsable des relations fédérales
provinciales aujourd'hui sur Roberge
qu'elle devait quitter
son poste ça ne passe pas écrit-il elle
doit démissionner si elle ne le fait pas
le gouvernement doit la démettre sans
délai je vous fais écouter a rafale donc
là ça va de elle doit partir on vient de
l'entendre on vient de le voir le livre
je dois réfléchir le chef du blog j'ai
demandé de la rencontrer les
conservateurs veulent qu'elle parte et
Monsieur Trudeau qui dit non non on la
garde on écoute tout ça on revient
j'ai demandé conséquemment en tant que
deuxième groupe d'opposition deuxième
opposition dans ce Parlement là qui vote
les budgets avec lesquels l'institution
pour laquelle elle va ouvrir et financer
de la rencontrer je veux avoir une
explication une meilleure compréhension
ce que je constate c'est que Monsieur
Trudeau ne met quelqu'un qui comme lui
nourrit la confrontation et nourrit la
discorde alors que le travail premier
d'un Premier ministre c'est justement de
l'acide de réunir les gens
et il faut pas laisser planer que les
Québécois seraient des gens
systématiquement racistes ou fermer à
des religions ou fermées à des des
gens qui viendraient d'autres pays c'est
faux c'est faux c'est faux le Québec est
un endroit très accueillant les
Québécois sont accueillants sont
fraternités
par les fonds publics je trouve ça très
glissant
je pense qu'elle a clarifié sa position
et je suis aussi d'accord que c'est
clairement une enjeu un problème
national un problème qui existe à
travers le pays effectivement c'est un
problème qui existe en les autres pays
aussi et
c'est important qu'on reconnaître c'est
un problème
c'est important d'avoir des gens qui
peuvent parler pour la communauté et
c'est quelqu'un qui connaît très bien la
communauté
musulmane y compris au Québec et qui est
là pour exprimer leurs inquiétudes
[Applaudissements]
oui ça satisfait le Premier ministre
alors tour de table peut-elle doit-elle
Hélène Buzzetti restait
moi je vois très pas je vois pas du tout
comment elle peut rester écouter vous
vous situez certaines de ces
déclarations mais en fait il y en a
d'autres qui commencent à sortir
notamment une qui date de 2013 à
l'époque où le Parti québécois était au
pouvoir avec sa charte des valeurs et
Madame el ghaouabi cité un penseur
canadien Legend of qui nous disait à
l'époque en disait au 19e siècle les
occidentaux étaient à des peurs peur de
quoi faire de perdre la pureté pureté du
sang pureté de la race et Madame el
ghaouabi enchaînant en disait il
pourrait aussi bien parler du Québec
alors essentiellement elle accuse des
Québécois de chercher à protéger la
pureté de la race alors je ne sais pas
si confronté à ces nouvelles
déclarations en fait de vieilles
déclarations mais qui nous sont
nouvellement portant notre attention si
Monsieur Trudeau pourra encore la
défendre mais ça va devenir de plus en
plus difficile pour lui surtout dans le
contexte là où évidemment le
gouvernement kakis
exploite cette situation pour bien
marquer ses propres positions et dans un
contexte aussi où Monsieur Trudeau c'est
quand même attiré quelques foudres par
rapport à son renvoi envisagé sur la loi
21 ça va commencer à être difficile pour
lui de tenir tout ça ok Michel
je pense que c'est Monsieur Blanchette
qui a raison ce qu'on peut pas lui
parler avant de destiner qu'il faut que
ça aille
là où je me suis le ministre sa
gouvernementale à Québec dit il faut il
faut qu'elle s'en aille c'est basé sur
un tweet écoutez on peut se parler avant
de décider ça et je pense que prendre un
petit peu plus de temps puis que des
personnes puissent se rencontrer
Monsieur Robert je pourrais demander de
la rencontrer c'est pas un sport hors de
l'ordre des choses et donc vous dites le
gouverneur du Québec Michel est allé
trop loin
peut-être que c'est peut-être qu'à la
fin c'est ça qui sera la décision mais
est-ce qu'on peut faire ça sur la base
d'autres choses qu'un truc s'il vous
plaît allez
je pense que ce sera difficile pour
madame
el-ghaouabid de couper ses fonctions à
partir du moment où une grande partie de
la population canadienne nommément les
Québécois ne vont lui accorder aucune
crédibilité son rôle c'est de rétablir
les ponts entre les communautés
expliquer parler de la communauté
musulmane c'est ce que c'est ce que
Justin Trudeau a dit maintenant que ça
crédibilité elle va être difficile à
établir au Québec
à ce moment-là ce que c'est la bonne
personne pour faire le travail pour
lequel elle a été embauchée parce qu'on
a bien fait
Ottawa la révision de son dossier ou
alors on l'a nommé en sachant qu'elle
traînait toutes sortes de casseroles ce
qui est propre particulièrement une
bonne chose sinon ben j'ai l'impression
que c'est un peu son entrée en scène est
un peu saboter puis ça va être difficile
pour le gouvernement de lui faire jouer
le rôle peut-être qu'elle devait jouer à
partir de ce moment-là ce que ça reste
une bonne nomination s'il ne peut pas
parler à un quart de la population
canadienne pas certain peut-être qu'on
devrait reconsidérer le poste la
personne qui occupe le poste parce que
ce qu'on lui reproche ceux qui veulent
qu'elles partent ou en tout cas qui
réfléchissent très sérieusement ce
qu'elle part ce qu'on lui reproche c'est
de pas qu'elle soit contre la loi 21 ça
je pense que tout le monde aura compris
qu'elle soit contre la charte à l'époque
mais c'est la généralisation après de 0
Québec ce sentiment anti-musulman c'est
ça qui passe pas là c'est ça qui vous
fait dire vous que en fait attendez on
va écouter pour donner le temps parce
que c'est à chacun au début Pablo
Rodriguez
c'est lui notre ami loué à tarois qui
lui a parlé vendredi d'un corridor lui
était fâché
je suis profondément blessé
par ses propos je suis profondément
insultés par ces propos et je m'attends
à ce que les retire aujourd'hui
elle apporte tirer
non pas du tout et en fait vous l'avez
dit elle n'aime pas la loi 21 il y a
rien de mal à ça on peut avoir un débat
là-dessus aucun problème le problème
c'est que elle elle estime comme
beaucoup d'autres gens d'ailleurs que la
loi 21 elle s'appuie elle s'explique par
de l'islamophobie très très présente au
Québec et ça c'est ce que j'appelle moi
les deux solitudes au Canada sur la loi
21 c'est que en général et j'insiste
c'est évidemment il y a des exceptions
des deux côtés mais en général au Canada
on considère la religion comme faisant
partie de l'identité alors qu'au Québec
on a tendance à voir la religion comme
une idée et une idée peut être critiquée
elle peut même être ridiculisée et en
tout cas contenu dans son expression
parfois alors que une identité doit être
acceptée et c'est pour ça que pour
beaucoup de Canadiens qui qui sont dans
ce cet état d'esprit pour eux vouloir
empêcher des symboles religieux c'est
s'attaquer à l'identité des gens et donc
à être discriminatoire à leurs endroits
alors que pour bien des Québécois c'est
dire ben non c'est seulement des idées
et on estime que des endroits où dans la
fonction publique par exemple où on ne
peut pas exprimer des idées comme
d'ailleurs des idées politiques alors il
est là le grand fossé entre les deux
visions et c'est ça qui dérange tant
c'est cette façon cette adéquation fait
entre loi 21
= islamophobie et je rappelle quand même
parce qu'il y a quelqu'un qui est
mentionnait mais c'est quand même un
salaire là de 167 à 191000 dollars c'est
un gros poste et il me semble-t-il que
lorsque vous avez le corps de la
population qui était chaude et peut-être
que ça commence mal comme mandat
encore une fois on peut être totalement
quelqu'un qui a ce genre de poste là on
peut comprendre très bien que la loi 21
c'est pas le modèle de loi qu'on veut
Michel C et Alex c'est clair c'est c'est
le
c'est le passage au général puis c'est
le laisser entendre que au Québec on est
pardon
c'est la généralisation
comme ça on l'accepterait pas de dire
les albertés sont comme ça ça pose pas
mieux au Québec
il y a différents
mais bien sûr ok Alex donc conclusion
là-dessus monsieur Trudeau va attendre
quelques quelques semaines quelques
jours voir ce talent
il peut il peut tenir à son choix s'il
le veut mais il sera pas capable
d'utiliser les services de Madame
melgawaby pour passer le message qu'il
souhaite au Québec ça m'apparaît assez
clair que à partir de maintenant si la
garde en poste elle sera la
représentante de la lutte contre
l'homophobie au Canada anglais
ok rentrer par le menteur aujourd'hui
Ottawa donc première question de Pierre
Poirier s'intéressant lui le cheval
McKenzie on va l'entendre souvent
enfourchez ce cheval de bataille en
disant vous avez donné de l'argent à vos
petits amis monsieur Trudeau petit
extrait et c'était sa première question
en français ce poignet
ce premier ministre a doublé notre dette
nationale ajoutant 500 milliards de
dollars de déficit
inflationnistes donc oui étaler l'argent
et maintenant on sait des contrats pour
les amis du Premier ministre on sait
qu'il y a 15 milliards de dollars de
plus dans ces contrats combien parmi ces
dollars ont allé chez Mackenzie il a 7
ans quand on s'est fêté lire comme
gouvernement on a fait la promesse
d'investir dans la classe moyenne et
tous ceux qui allaient travailler fort
pour ci-joint des c'est exactement ce
qu'on a fait on a pu créer des millions
d'emplois tout en sortant des millions
de personnes de la pauvreté
malheureusement à chaque étape le Parti
conservateur était contre
vous avez compris que ça a été Michel si
au jour un dialogue de sourds pas
vraiment parler de Mackenzie des deux
côtés alors il y a une commission
parlementaire ma question toute simple
pour vous trois est-ce que Mackenzie ça
va commencer à chialer un peu le
gouvernement
ou pas dans quelle mesure Michel
le nom est devenu toxique puis pas juste
au Canada aller voir les journaux
français qui en parle même au Québec il
y a un énorme malaise que dans plein
milieu de la pandémie le gouvernement
est fait appel avec
il y a ce livre des journalistes de
Newton c'est certainement ces gens-là
quand tu rentres d'une place ça sera
pour beau alors le nom est toxique le
nom est devenu toxique et
il y a rien de bon qui peut sortir de là
le gouvernement doit le plus rapidement
on a doublé la date nationale de sa peau
de Mackenzie d'ailleurs une question de
proportion qu'il faut respecter là mais
à la fin
il y a un problème à utiliser de façon
aussi systématique ce même groupe de
consultants qui ont pas la meilleure
réputation au monde
Mackenzie est pas un très gros joueur
dans les contrats externes donner à des
films de consultants Ottawa en fait
c'est un joueur qui est politiquement
controversé Michel vient de le dire
parce qu'il
occupe une devant de la scène dans
plusieurs pays depuis maintenant
quelques années mais en terme de
contrôle de loies pmeg
poils s'accentuer bref tous ceux qui
donnent des conseils au gouvernement ont
beaucoup beaucoup vu leur contrat
augmenter depuis maintenant quelques
années moi j'espère qu'on va pas
uniquement parler de mécanique qui a un
petit côté politique intéressant étant
donné que Dominique Barton conseiller
juste un Trudeau de dire ambassadeur en
Chine et dirigeant Mackenzie avant et ça
je comprends les liens c'est bien de
faire la lumière là-dessus pour voir
s'il y a pas eu de favoritisme mais une
fois ceci dit 116 millions de dollars
depuis une dizaine d'années dans la
monssellement de milliards de dollars de
contrats donnés à des firmes privées ce
n'est pas énorme moi c'est toute la
sous-traitance qui m'intéresse à ces
cabinets conseils là pourquoi on n'est
pas capable de faire ça à l'interne
est-ce que ça fonctionne si vous êtes 44
millions de dollars donnés 23 par
exemple je me trompe dans mes chiffres
je pense à 23 millions qui a été donné
au ministère de l'immigration dans les
trois dernières années on peut pas dire
que le ministère de l'immigration est
très performant depuis trois ans parce
que ces millions là donne quelque chose
encore qu'on a donné à toutes les
gouvernement dans le monde qu'on paye le
gros prix alors que dans le fond c'est
les mêmes choses qu'on a recommandé
ailleurs ça ça m'intéresse mais Kensi
c'est comme le petit aspect croustillant
mais le fond je pense pour les Denis
publics et plus intéressants ça peut
être aussi le canari dans la mine ça
peut être là on le voit on ne voit que
mécaniser mais peut-être ça va révéler
espèce de culture de aller à l'extérieur
parce qu'on a affaibli la fonction
publique ce que venait de dire
finalement Hélène oui à l'école raison
on veut savoir si en fait c'est un autre
rapport gros action là qui est
photographié puis qui nous dépasse
ont raison le 100 millions de dollars à
peu près on n'a pas le détail exact mais
elle a un mekkenzie c'est une goutte
d'eau dans quand monsieur broyait le met
tout ça il y a 500 milliards ajouter sur
la dette il est d'une grande maladie
intellectuelle c'est une goutte d'eau
dans les dépenses pandémique mais
effectivement les débats soulevés sont
extrêmement importants
clairement les conservateurs vont
essayer d'épingler ça encore comme un
autre cas de favoritisme en soulignant
comme le dialecte le passage de
Dominique Parton de chez Mackenzie à
ambassadeur pour le Canada je pense que
le côté toxique de Mackenzie comme le
dit Michel va peut-être venir à la
rescousse un petit peu du gouvernement
libéral en ce sens que compte tenu que
mécanisme comme ça cette réputation très
mauvaise dans le monde mais qui donne
des conseils partout dans le monde ça va
être plus difficile de prouver que dans
le cas canadien c'est vraiment parce
qu'on est copains copains entre les
libéraux et Mackenzie qu'on est donné
ces contrats alors cette preuve là de
favoritisme va être plus difficile à
établir pour les conservateurs mais
néanmoins c'est un débat extrêmement
important
je voulais vous parler d'électricité
j'en parle pas parce qu'on a pas assez
de temps puis on va faire ça de façon
plus efficace non mais on va y revenir
Michel parce que demain c'est la comme
ça parlementaire
combien il reste
oh on peut peut-être faire une petite
prolongation rapidement sur les Michels
je vous passe la parole alors rapport
présentation Thomas Gerber a obtenu la
présentation des droits Québec qui
montre que si on disait oui à toutes les
entreprises qui émergents qui veulent
l'électricité pas cher ça prendrait 13
romaines le dollar à mort dont parlait
c'est ça dont on parlait
la Romaine c'est pas un barrage c'est
quatre barrages alors
la semaine dernière
pour faire ça et ils m'ont dit qu'à 5 là
ça prendrait
on est en plein Dollarama et on est
templé dans les choix qu'il faut faire
et il faudrait que le gouvernement
comprenne qu'il y a des choix à faire
avec Hélène rapidement comme l'éclair
comme l'électricité
je pense que le gouvernement est très au
courant que des choix à faire je pense
qu'ils vont le faire ils ont d'ailleurs
déjà commencé dans ce projet de loi 2
qui va étudier demain on va permettre au
Québec de refuser des projets de moins
de 50 MW ce qui ne pouvaient pas faire
jusqu'ici on est en train de s'ajuster
c'est un beau débat qui commence je
pense le gouvernement c'est très bien
que son électricité convoitait
maintenant qu'est-ce qu'on va faire pour
maximiser le potentiel d'électricité à
bas prix du Québec ça ça va être
vraiment très intéressant et la
conclusion à tous les égards il y a
aussi la question des autosé
lectriques et d'électricité si toutes
les maisons qui ont encore des
fournaises au gaz pas à l'électricité on
manquerait de puissance pendant les mois
d'hiver le débat il est plus large et
c'est sûr oui la sobriété énergétique
mais en son sens là bon ben voilà
pourquoi j'ai douté qu'on pouvait pas
faire ça désolé d'avoir douté merci
beaucoup
à bientôt merci beaucoup au revoir pour
voir nos émissions en entier rendez-vous
sur la chaîne ici RDI